foreign
okay wait let's start okay we can do
like I I I'll say you look amazing
what's going on thank you okay you're
ready okay okay
all right I am trying so hard to be the
person that is running this interview
but with Katie Kirk I have a strong
feeling that you are going to take over
well no I'm not gonna take over but I am
going to ask you a lot of questions
because I I haven't talked to you in a
long time I'm such a fan of Whitney's
everyone I love her I think she's
amazing and so I am gonna ask you a
little bit about your life but if this
is your podcast honey so you take it
they're so sick of me at this point I do
think there is La New York I feel like
there's you know look I have more
criticisms about La culture than anyone
but I do think that the wellness you
know bullshit stereotype still there but
also there's a lot of new
um developments in the anti-aging space
that are super legit yeah just because
I'm from LA please don't think that this
is bullshit
um uh besides uh eating babies or
whatever people think we're doing in la
oh placenta well there's that but
there's like the conspiracy theory that
we that Hollywood people uh eat
adrenochrome which is one of you you
haven't even heard this hasn't even got
to you okay we get it okay tell me what
is it it's no there was a conspiracy
theory that uh that Hollywood people
when babies are scared they produce a
chemical called adrenochrome and you
take their stem cells and it makes you
younger how do you get the stem cells
from the babies you have to put them in
a smoothie I mean it's it's not true I
swear to God people it's like in the
same there's the same people with like
the Jewish lasers yes it's the uh the
Jews control the weather
um and uh what's the other oh like
Hillary Clinton there was a pizza oh
yeah that's in Dupont Circle in
Washington yeah they did a whole talk
about that yeah that's sort of mkrc
theories are so fascinating like what is
it about conspiracy theories that make
people believe them and I have this
theory about conspiracy theories is that
people with the sort of fragmentation of
society with the fact that a lot of our
institutions were that were formally
gathering places like churches and
synagogues and community centers and and
that was exacerbated during covet I
think people are lonely and have this
desire for the sense of belonging so
they join whatever crazy club that
they're influenced by and they start
they there's a certain community in
people who believe in conspiracy
theories or people who are super
right-wing zealots you know and and and
and it has this ability to make to to
make people more cohesive or something
but it is so weird isn't it it is let's
get it and it's also just ignorance and
I I mean is it fair to say it's a lack
of Education I don't know or being able
to be a critical thinker or being a
follower I don't know what it is I also
think there are and this is not me
defending most of the conspiracy
theories out there but when it comes to
someone like Alex Jones you know he's
basically a drug dealer he's dealing
adrenaline and adrenaline is addictive
adrenaline turns into dopamine so you
know people that I feel uh that feel
like they've been subjugated and
oppressed by this upper class like to
them I think it's like might as well be
true in a way yeah I guess on the other
hand you know that to me was the most
heinous kind of conspiracy theory that
these suffering families many have whom
I know from from Newtown Connecticut
from Sandy Sandy Hook that somehow this
didn't happen I mean it is such it is so
grotesque but do you think on some way
because I think that people tend to
adhere to a theory that soothes them in
some way either malign the enemy with
their rapists or this they eat babies it
makes me feel better about my choices
but do you think on any level you know I
think I have a lot of denial in uh parts
of my life where that involves grief the
way my dad passed away I have a lot of
denial about it in a way I have a
conspiracy theory the opposite direction
like I'm like oh no he just peacefully
died in his sleep because what actually
happened is just two
um uh sort of intrusive and upsetting to
accept on the other level do you think
the people that have to go like oh yeah
Newtown must have been fake or whatever
do you think on some level that's a
coping mechanism of I can't accept that
these children were got shot I I just
don't give them credit for having it as
a coping mechanism I think it is
you know I mean if it was a coping
mechanism we would need them every day
yeah you know for Walmart for you know
the the gay club in Colorado Springs I
mean for what happened at UVA I mean
every day we would just have to deny the
truth so I I think there is something
worse than that I think it's something
more more malevolent and I think Alex
Jones is Carnival Barker and the most
disgusting kind of person who preys on
people's gullibility and
um you know just just makes money and
and you see the products he Hawks I mean
he's just disgusting and I'm so glad
they won that case yeah and it's tricky
because I think that you know uh the
Epstein thing it was really wild because
he he was saying you know uh politicians
go to a pedophile Island he wasn't and
it ended up having like by the time the
Epstein thing came out it was like oh
see he was right oh and then it was like
well then he must be right about more
stuff so I have to confess I mean I do
not follow Alex Jones super carefully
but it's funny you know once in a while
when there's something when I tweet
something or put something on social
media everyone's like well you had
dinner you know you hung out with
Jeffrey Epstein and I'm always like read
my book idiot
um you know I went to because prince
Andrew and was having dinner with
Jeffrey Epstein I was never told who
Jeffrey Epstein was it was just like can
you come to this biggest single family
dwelling in New York City uh George
Stephanopoulos is going to be there it's
a dinner in honor prince Andrew and then
I thought well gosh George is there
maybe I should go and The Royal Wedding
was going to take place that spring so I
didn't want them to have a competitive
Advantage so I said okay I'll go and
Chelsea Handler and I were supposed to
have dinner that night so I said do you
want to go to this dinner I don't really
know what it's going to be like but it
should be interesting the house is
interesting I think I Googled Jeffrey
Epstein and of course the thing before I
got there the thing came that what came
out is that he had gotten off that
remember that thing in Florida and that
lawyer and so I thought well that's kind
of sketchy but it wasn't the full story
of what Jeffrey Epstein had actually
done but anyway it's just so funny
because that has gotten spun into this
whole big thing that you know based
basically I was picturing young girls
for Jeffrey but that's disgusting
because
because I'm not
talking about because it really it
really bothers me when women who we
already tend to have to work twice as
hard to get half as far also have to be
held accountable and speak for the bad
behavioral Point Whitney I think a lot
of people you know I always want to say
I am not I was not Matt's babysitter you
know and it is very interesting how
quickly it turns from whatever you know
his behavior was to what did people know
and why wasn't he stopped and listen I
think that's a legitimate question when
it comes to his superiors his bosses but
his co-workers I think the onus should
not be on US unless someone comes to us
obviously exactly unless you have
information I have a real problem or do
you know something that's going on
people's bad behavior they keep it a
great secret you know well he was
extremely discreet I have to say and
um you know and and seemingly
compartment analyzed his behavior and uh
you know
it just it's just strange for people to
say about even Savannah or Hodor people
who were with him more recently
what did you know and when did you know
it and you know Matt was doing things
very surreptitiously and
um and and certainly wasn't something
that I was aware of and what I will say
when you know people come to me as soon
as a male comedian right you know is
found out for some kind of you know
nefarious behavior
um it's always what did you know and why
didn't you do anything you must have
known I'm like okay first of all I'm
already having to work twice as hard to
get half as far second of all I don't go
out of my way to go through the cell
phone photos of my male comedian friends
I'm not here to I'm not checking IDs at
the door that's someone else's job you
know and you know well it's almost like
you know all Comedians and and I think
they this was portrayed for the Today
Show as well like we all got on a bus
after the show and went on a picnic and
we spent all our down time together and
it's almost like there's this club of
Comedians and that you all you know live
in a trailer somewhere or live in a you
know house somewhere and you go from gig
to Gig yeah it's like what yeah yeah
totally and you know I go so far as to
say if I see male comedians cheating on
and they're married I'm still not going
to get involved that's none of my
business number one it's not illegal
this is between you and I don't know
what your Arrangement is with your wife
or your family and it's you know I don't
want to set the example that hey if
you're going to be a woman in a male
dominated field not only do you have to
work twice as hard to get half as far
and as a comedian you know female Comics
were the most hated species on the
planet well already you know basically
within five minutes of getting on stage
where the woman that you know uh took
half of your money in the divorce where
your mom that didn't breastfeed you or
the girl that didn't screw you in high
school you know and were basically women
that are give complaining and giving our
opinions and the the whole Arrangement
is you do not get to have sex with us at
the end this isn't a date where if you
listen to my stories you might you know
be able to hook up with me later the
arrangement is you pay me for my opinion
so it's already you know a job that's
you know uh pushing it but do you think
I mean but before we talk about that I
just wanted to mention one thing like I
thought it was so weird when because
Meryl Streep had been in movies Miramax
movies somehow she was being held
accountable for Harvey Weinstein's
Behavior I mean I think that's just
another example of of women being blamed
for Men Behaving Badly but when it comes
to comedians don't you think that's
changed some do you think women
comedians are more accepted because I
remember like there have been so many
articles about this Whitney like over
the years and I don't know I just wonder
has it changed or not I think so you
know I think that female I think
comedians in general are always going to
be in acquired taste you know not only
because comedy is incredibly subjective
it's super emotional we're holding up
the mirror to everyone's insecurities
you know political leaning sometimes we
say things that are incendiary on
purpose and a lot of what we do is we're
going to say the craziest thing maybe
the meanest thing and in the past 10 15
years that's not necessarily a super
hard thing to find with Twitter with our
former president you can find mean nasty
insults and hot takes and ridiculous
opinions anytime you want you know you
can go to the comments section of any
YouTube and you'll see just the most
brutal horrible words being said crazy
you know outlandish things you can go to
Alex Jones you know to hear ridiculous
you know uh takes and you know paranoia
and
um so it used to kind of be that we were
the One-Stop shop for sort of hideous
thoughts uh saying all the things you
can't say anywhere else you know testing
the boundaries of the First Amendment so
I think that the job of a comedian is
really changing right now it's very
interesting and we were talking briefly
before the camera started rolling about
um you know comedians getting canceled
and sort of changing and I I've been
fascinated to see how sometimes like
Sarah Silverman has said in the past she
has been insensitive or she regrets some
of her comedy and I'm curious how you
feel about that and and and and
additionally there was something so
interesting I think John's brother sent
him a video of Norm Macdonald I don't
know if you've seen this I don't know if
there's a at the Emmys or what a some
awards ceremony brought out a Native
American and full Native American Garb
and started riffing and mocking Marlon
Brando I guess
um and this was I don't I it'd be
interesting to find the date
Jon Stewart was shot in the audience
laughing hysterically there were a lot
of people and it just did not age well I
have to be honest it didn't age well and
my husband and I watched it we were like
wow you you could not do that today and
it did seem distasteful I have to be
honest you know and
um I'm just curious I know this is yours
you're making these incredible points
and I just I didn't know if talking
about comedy would even be interesting
to you because oh yeah that's super I
mean you're super interesting to me I
think this is the perfect time to talk
about it because so much of what I think
you know comedians the impossibly high
standards were being held to is a lot
because
um you know you've always known this
we've always kind of known this on some
level I'm from DC that this in the last
10 years in the Zeitgeist the pulling
the curtain behind of a lot of our
authority figures being so corrupt and
be and there's so much uh corruption
within
um politics now that it was always
probably there and maybe worse before
but now we just have a you know I don't
know if it was ever worse I mean I I
think Donald Trump has brought it to a
whole new level sure and I never know
with stuff like when people say Cancer's
at an all-time high you're like is it an
all-time high or was it just easier to
diagnose was it you don't want people to
say why are there all these trans people
all of a sudden you go wait a second are
there more trans people now than ever or
are they just more comfortable being
trans exactly and we're able to see
their Instagram posts and they're able
to make themselves visible so I kind of
never really know exactly and that's not
something that's actually a good point
and I agree I sometimes wonder that
myself yeah I don't know because if
you're a politician 100 years ago you
could probably get away with way more
than you can now because there were no
camera phones and there was no way to
yeah well secretly certainly
extramarital Affairs for sure for sure
you know but um you know and also with
this you know in the last 10 years which
I think is your uh uniquely qualified to
weigh in on this with the most authority
of the
um sort of distrust all-time high
distrusted meet in journalism and in the
news people are now going to comedians
to you know post Johnson are going well
your fake news a lot of kids are getting
their news from Tick Tock a lot of
people are getting their news from late
night they want comedians all of a
sudden to be moral authority figures
because you guys are the ones that speak
truth to Authority and you tell the
truth and Jon Stewart became sort of who
everyone started trusting right
journalist even though he was a comedian
so people are now putting these isn't
possibly high moral standards on us when
we're like wait we're the scumbags I
mean I don't even know if I'd call Jon
Stewart I would call him a social
commentator you know 100 right not a
journalist so I think but but but I
don't think I wouldn't call him a
comedian either he's this hybrid person
and I would say the same of of Stephen
Colbert probably probably a little less
of Jimmy Fallon because I think he stays
away from the political stuff because he
got so much trouble when he tussled
Donald Trump's hair when he he was on
his show I got a lot of
um Flack because I did the Donald Trump
roast 13 years ago and this was before
anyone you know had any idea who was
really running for office right we heard
we were writing jokes about it you know
if he's running for president and we
made jokes about it being a publicity
stunt we didn't know that it was a very
calculated move as someone who is a he's
you know a media kind of Genius right
ways he knew that being punched being
insulted by Hollywood Elites is going to
make me more likable and he knew the
power of a roast and publicly allowing
yourself to be made the underdog makes
other people like you I think maybe
that's giving him a little too much
credit but why do you still get
criticized I mean I do think he's a
brilliant marketer and he's great I mean
disgustingly great at worms like fake
news and kind of mocking people and
coming up with little monikers for for
people but but so 13 years ago you did
this roast and then he runs for
president and people were saying why
were you saying you normalized him
normalized you made him seem like an
underdog you know you made him seem like
a victim and it made him likeable like
oh you know these bully comedians are
beating up on him yeah you know and he
has a sense of humor and he took it and
so when he went from being the bully to
being bullied and it made him sort of
more likable I mean after that set you
know we were here it was Larry King and
you know it was in a ham at the hammer
Ballroom yeah it was uh it was the
Friars Club right
because he was always on the Today show
with The Apprentice but he was a lot
more less repugnant back then than he
was once he ran for office don't get me
wrong we now know what uh corrupt
businessman he was and how he didn't pay
people but and and also how he you know
the Discrimination that we saw with the
apartment buildings and all the stuff
that has come to light but back then he
was sort of thought of as an affable
buffoon sort of yeah and and and maybe
buffoon is even too strong a word but
just kind of a you know the Donald right
this sort of tacky businessman who was
never really accepted by New York
Society right so in a weird way he was
kind of the underdog back then I don't
know I mean obviously what was Unleashed
during the presidential run and this
this kind of power he amassed in in
politics I think Brian brought out the
very worst in him as a malignant
narcissist but back then it it was just
different and I think that's one thing
that's really something we we don't
think about or we have this knee-jerk
reaction when we see things that like
the the American the Native American man
who they were kind of making fun of
I think you have to also consider the
times that we were living in it doesn't
make it any less
um sort of offensive but it just makes
it a little more understandable a 100
percent with comedy context is
everything and comedy is sort of meant
to work uh in an ephemeral sort of way
it's like fashion you know we don't look
back you know of what someone was
wearing 30 years ago and go oh she has
terrible taste like you're like no at
the time that's was right style I know
and sometimes I see old pictures of me
and I was like I actually left my house
thinking I look good
I don't know about that but it's just
funny yeah and you look back and you're
like I was doing the best I could at the
time with the tools I had and you know I
think that it's the kind of you know
again as a comedian I tend to just sort
of like often take Devil's Advocate or
add context to things that's what we do
uh often at Great cost you know who do
we get mad at uh when Norm brings out a
Native American and it looks bad do we
laugh at the do we get angry at the
person that did it or the people who
laughed same with Donald Trump doing
about it Donald Trump or do we get mad
at all the people that voted for him
we'll have about all I don't know the
answer yes but I don't even know if it's
mad it's just like wow you know it's
just it's just interesting to observe
how things change and you know what is
acceptable
what was acceptable then versus what is
acceptable now and you were talking
about political correctness and comedy
and that it's everyone has gotten a
little too sensitive in your view and
here's what I'll say I actually don't
find that as a bad thing I think that
you know people getting sensitive or not
wanting comedians to make jokes about
fat chicks or make racist jokes about
black people I think I think that's a
good thing I think it you know
challenges us and forces us to level up
and play the top of our not punch down
yeah I think it's I it's a good thing
you know I'm always looking for you know
more and more boundaries that forces us
to be more clever and ultimately it's
not my decision what people think is
funny I work for the audience if you
guys don't want to hear that kind of
stuff anymore I'm gonna evolve and
change I you know to me I think that
being a comedian often means staying
quite immature and I like it when people
force me to be more mature another thing
I'll say is that I don't complain about
all the eggshells on the ground and
cancel culture Etc because you know I
think it's going to not only make comedy
better but it's going to make the art
and you know performance of Comedy way
more interesting for everyone because
four years ago everyone was so
desensitized nothing you couldn't build
any tension there was in the news there
was conversations about a p the
president's P tape Stormy Daniels was
the front page of everything there was
no way to shock anyone you know as a
comedian you go on stage you couldn't
say anything to shock people now there's
tension again there's eggshells on on
the ground again and comedy feels
dangerous so for me it makes comedy way
more fun and do you think that's
people's sensitivities have gone
overboard that you know that they're
that there's so much material that is
simply off limits or when you're talking
about any group that may be
disenfranchised or marginalized or
whatever you know that that you can't go
there or you have to really think about
how you approach that like anything
specific kind of humor it's always been
the case you just have to be smart about
it you uh have to uh be you know careful
in the way that you craft your set
context is everything I'll say two
things number one I think comedians are
making a huge mistake right now in uh
basically giving out their comedy for
free online on Twitter Etc where they
have no idea when it's going to be read
by who uh what the context is going to
be in so say you have a great abortion
joke that when you're you know in the
basement of a comedy club at 9 00 PM
when it's dark people have signed up to
come see comedy they're already primed
for this and don't you think they want
to feed me made to don't you think they
want to be made to feel uncomfortable I
think absolutely I think people are
signing up it's like going to a haunted
house you're signing up to be scared
you're going to horror movie you're
signing up to watch people get murdered
if you're just walking down the street
you don't want to see that when you
haven't paid money and emotionally
prepared for it but what comedians are
doing is right now you're putting your
abortion joke on Twitter at two in the
afternoon on a Tuesday that's not when
comedy is supposed to be given to people
you don't know where your joke is going
why are they doing that you know I think
that comedians are looking for you know
new audiences anywhere new audiences
looking to build followings you know but
I think comedian comedy always needs to
be delivered by the comedian because if
I just write a joke out and give it to
you you're now trusting someone else to
deliver it the way you know they're not
going to do it with a wink and a smile
it's not between 20 minutes of jokes I
was gonna say it's not where they talk
contact
you know so and it could be posted or
retweeted to someone that doesn't follow
you that doesn't know who you are that
didn't sign up for your irreverent
comedy and it could come between two
tweets about a school shooting you know
and all of a sudden it's not as funny
anymore so I think that it's we don't
have I obviously we don't have a free
speech problem we have a speech for
foodie problem why are you giving out
your comedy for free to a bunch of
people that are gonna go out of their
way to intentionally misunderstand what
you're doing in order to justify being
offended yeah you know so I think most
people don't want you know football I
love watching football on Sundays with a
beer and some guys I got my computer and
I don't want to just have someone force
me to watch football on a Tuesday when
I'm at work yeah doing something else
you know so I think comedians were
sensitive by Nature were incredibly
um histrionic we have histrionic
dramatic reactions to everything so
there's no surprise that we have
histrionic dramatic reactions that now
we're finding out that a couple people
don't think we're funny and we're losing
our minds yeah you know so I think we're
also doing comedy for people that just
aren't comedy fans so when did you
decide you wanted to go to to go into
comedy because we should tell the story
about how our paths crossed I don't know
we were there at the same time or not
but we both worked at WRC uh the MVC 0-0
TV station in Washington DC where
Willard Scott would give the local yeah
another report and he was Ronald
McDonald back in the day and he was also
a joy boy of radio which you have to be
really ancient to remember that he would
do the smucker brought to you by
Smuckers happy birthday to the oldest
people yeah and you were an intern right
you worked with Barbara Harrison who's
still a good friend of mine I was an
intern for Barbara Harrison in
Washington DC my mom worked at the
Bloomingdale's Tyson's Corner White
Flint you know Barbara came in all the
time to get her Christmas gifts and
stuff and Barbara was a local anchor
everyone and really really wonderful
person and I became close to her because
her husband died of colon cancer sir I
think before my husband died of colon
cancer it was very strange but anyway so
you're you're you're helping Barbara at
WRC I got to go into The Newsroom as
they were choosing the local news
stories and stuff and um and I was I I
went to Annenberg School of
Communications at Penn I wanted to be a
journalist but I really struggled with
being objective so I remember one day
they let me read the teleprompter and
like read the local news uh so that I
had like a real oh that's so cute yeah
what I had I went to a Buffalo Exchange
which is a secondhand store and I found
a Thomas pink shirt oh that's a good
find I know it really did not fit me at
all I was sweating I had giant pit stain
and you know local news in DC is always
going to be pretty wild yeah something
about a child that had gotten kidnapped
and yeah since I was very young always
used humor to cut tension and to cope
with grief so I make inappropriate jokes
when when I feel uncomfortable you know
when things get too serious I grow up in
an alcoholic home where things were
always very tense and if you could just
you know I was that's why I loved
watching Roseanne growing up it was all
just
um you know a family using jokes and
humor to cope with an impossible
situation so that was sort of you know a
muscle I knew I had
um and especially very dark things I
always felt the need to laugh you know
I'd laugh at funerals and then be
miserable at parties I was like
something's off I must be a comedian and
uh so the prompter came up and I started
reading it it was about a boy that had
gotten kidnapped and they couldn't find
him and the kid you know there was a
photo that came up of him and he was a
corpulent little boy and I remember
going well very good word I I mean I'm
trying and we don't say fat anymore fat
kid
um and uh he came up this little uh you
know Butterball of a kid and I just was
like well the kidnapper is obviously
very strong if they were able to carry
him off you know I just started making
jokes you know I was just saying and
what was everyone around saying like it
was it was think it wasn't airing
anywhere no I know they were just doing
it yeah but people started laughing and
then I was like I know that I didn't get
the job No One's Gonna hire me but I
just learned in that moment was that
when you decided oh I'm gonna go into
common in that moment I pivoted a little
bit wow I think that there's something
broken about my brain where I can't
seriously talk about something tragic
without trying cracking a joke really to
make you think it's because of your
childhood and your dad and yes what
exactly happened to your dad you know
Mike I don't know this story and sorry
to say it's yeah it's um he had a stroke
both my parents had Strokes uh the same
year about uh 10 years ago and he was
basically paralyzed from the neck down
and um you know had a trach and his you
know how to top it could hardly you know
speak for years
um you know really awful and ultimately
you know and I don't know enough about
the subject even adequately criticized
the nursing home health care situation
in America I mean Healthcare in America
is just a disaster nightmare regardless
but he was in a nursing home in the
South it was a you know critical care
you know
Skilled Nursing Facility but in the
South uh if you have a child who is
mentally ill schizophrenic
um you know severely autistic and can't
take care of themselves a lot of times
they will take you know young kids in
their teens and 20s and put them in the
same facility as old people that also
need skilled care and there was I'm
gonna kind of not get too detailed about
it but there was a very mentally ill
schizophrenic person that basically
um
put up in a attacked him and he couldn't
survive
um you know so it was just sort of an
awful situation you know either way you
know by this time he was paralyzed from
the neck down it was going to be how old
either way probably 73 and get a stroke
very young and and
you said you grew up in an alcoholic
family you know when I say this in a
couple ways you know uh you know is
someone that I'm in recovery for um yeah
codependence I'm an Al-Anon adult child
of Alcoholics which is sort of you know
we're not addicted necessarily to
substances or drugs although some can be
I have a lot of that Addiction in my
family but you end up when you grow up
in a very chaotic environment like that
with Mercurial parents who are
overwhelmed or incapacitated you end up
being addicted to control Perfection
chaos adrenaline other addicts rescuing
people fixing people we say the 3ms
mothering micromanaging and martyring
ourselves you know so it's you know kind
of a a I think something that also
afflicts a lot of women in many ways
having an over developed sense of
responsibility thinking to solve
everyone else's problems and you take
care of everyone but yourself type thing
yeah at the expense of everyone nobody
wins though and we learn being nice is
not nice and in codependence we think we
have to solve everyone's problems for
them when in reality we're just
infantilizing them and not giving them
the Dignity of their own experience and
you know so I'm in recovery for that but
you know something that has really
helped me is to learn that in order for
alcoholism to be present alcohol doesn't
have to be present so you know a lot of
people think oh I didn't grow up and not
call a comb I didn't see someone
drinking whiskey out of a paper bag
right but you might see you know
unrecovered Alan onism you might be
seeing you know uh uh you know I think a
lot of what happened with Trump if I'm
to be honest is that he created uh the
sort of access to the internal medicine
cabinet of adrenaline causing people
this just constant adrenaline you know I
see people that are addicted to reading
about them addicted to thinking about
them you know because he creates
adrenaline and adrenaline turns into
dopamine so having you know chaos in the
home uh sex addiction love addiction
addictions to like cooking cleaning
Perfection stuff like that workaholism I
also think I have a lot of workaholism
in my my family I had a mom that worked
full-time and she was a full-time mom
and she was a full-time Entertainer and
and you know I don't think that it was
always a choice in terms of how hard she
worked you know at the time as a woman
I'm sure you know she had to work you
know her tush off but you know there was
a lot of addiction that wasn't
necessarily just someone drinking
alcohol
um sounds like you've had a lot of
um I mean obviously you know a lot about
it and you've had a lot of therapy to
kind of help you sort this out but do
you think most comedians have this sort
of you know this is the old Trope this
dark complicated background and the
Tears of a Clown and all that jazz do
you think that is is true or is that a
cliche I'll say two things about that
number one because I I do want to point
out the cognitive dissonance that most
people right now are engaging in with
that Trope of that stereotype of all
comedians are traumatized they must have
had horrible things happen in their life
but also the new thing is comedians are
bullies and they're hurting people you
know and I just invite people to sort of
think about what is your take exactly on
that you know because you know comedians
are punching down they're causing
violence with their jokes I'm like okay
I don't if you have data on that I would
love to see it but what the data we do
have is we just saw Chris rocket punched
in the face and no one even stood up no
one's no one stood up when it happened
no one cared you know we just uh we have
videos that's the weirdest thing I have
many thoughts we saw John Caparulo um at
the Hermosa comedy magic club a class
was thrown at him Jim Jeffries was
punched in the face on stage in
Australia we just saw a girl um the this
comedian Ariel had a beer can thrown at
her head you know so comedians are uh
under attack at the moment actually
physically but part of it don't you
think I feel like the world just feels
like it's unraveling you know you look
at these yeah it's true you look at
these shootings and you just think there
is I I mean every it's just feels like
people
don't have an escape valve or they're so
screwed up or they're so
full of anxiety and depression and anger
and resentment
that it just feels like Society is is
sick right now I will say in I right
after the pandemic you know all my all
the tours got canceled I did 70 cities
after that in theaters I would say 60 of
the shows there were physical fights
that broke out I think that people went
from you know post 911 We're All in This
Together to the pandemic of if your mask
is on wrong you're trying to kill my dad
yeah you know I think and everyone just
became your enemy you don't know who's
sick who's not we're moving through the
world with you could be sick and have no
symptoms you're not wearing your mask
right you could have covid if you get
close to me you're trying to kill my
children and I think it became this
feral everyone for their own I don't
know who's backed I don't know who has
covered right everyone's just your enemy
by default and proximity all of a sudden
became a super dangerous thing you know
of I'm shoulder to shoulder with someone
that I don't know especially in a comedy
venue when the whole business model is
you're you're going to be shoulder to
shoulder with a stranger and exhale
droplets on each other for two hours you
know I think that everyone is in so much
fear I think the you know media
obviously is in a tricky place where
they have to make money and you know
click bait works and they capitalize on
us being terrified and at a constant
state of fear and terrified of each
other I also think that uh the way this
country is is built it's like you know
this was an experiment you know and I
think now is where it's like okay the
rubber really hit the road in terms of
health care of like if you're giving
people putting them in a situation where
they have no hope and no no even a
delusional hope of upward Mobility which
we used to have this Reacts To Riches
anyone can Ascend their class it's now
you know I think people are like I have
nothing to live for that just must make
people lose their mind it's interesting
because I was involved I went to this
conference called Google Zeitgeist and I
did a breakfast with uh
other journalist David Sanger from The
New York Times and John Kelly who
started a new publication service I
don't know what you want to call it
called Puck and you know they asked me
what isn't getting enough attention and
I set income inequality because I think
it is fomenting so much
anger and class resentment and
hopelessness all the things that you
just described I think that it's at the
root cause of our polarization and I
feel like so many people who are not
doing well or in the middle of the
country
who aren't quote unquote Coast Elites
and there's plenty of people on the
coast who are not Elites who are
struggling too but they just don't feel
seen or heard and I also think it's it's
misogynism racism you know all of those
things I think my father-in-law says
Trump kind of pulled the lid off the
sewer and everything comes came spewing
out and I think with changing
demographics when you think about the
fact that by 2044 there's going to be a
majority minority population white
people will no longer be the majority in
this country that is extremely
threatening all the School shooters are
white guys you know as you know you know
there's been a little bit more hope with
women and people of color and people
that have been historically subjugated
but I think the white men who have you
know only moved to the world with
privilege all of a sudden it's like wait
a second I'm not I'm getting something
taken from me but on this at the same
time I mean are all white men privileged
no I mean I know that's a very
controversial thing to probably say but
I thought you know there are a lot of
people socioeconomically who may
be white and and yet because of their
circumstances yes they walk through the
world with certain privilege I
understand that and certain and and
emanating certain things that people of
color don't but but I also think there's
there is can sometimes be an issue with
generalizing all groups of people and
and I think we have to be careful about
that I mean I you know this is sort of a
Shaky Ground coming from a white
privileged woman but but I sometimes
think that
that we get make these blanket
statements that aren't necessarily Fair
agree and I think that for me I'll just
be personally is that you know and I'm
interested to hear this from you because
we really spend a lot of time talking
about how much harder it is to be a
woman in a male-dominated business at
least for me but I know for it has been
in a lot of ways and I've had my ass
grabbed by club Owners and I've gotten
paid less and this and that you know and
I can you know spend all day telling all
the reasons it's unfair but that's just
it's not interesting to me I signed up
for a you know job that is uh you know
has a lot of you know challenges in a
lot of ways but I also argue when people
say comedy is male dominated I'm like
yeah but it's also a traditionally very
female craft to just complain for hours
and hours and talk about your feelings
so it is a lot of men but they're doing
something that is traditionally very
feminine in a lot of ways but I know
that in the past couple years with this
sort of Reckoning and with more women
getting into comedy a lot of the things
that I was able to get away with before
for because I was a girl I can't get
away with anymore and it's like wait a
second I can't talk about sex anymore
all the time I can't make this joke and
I can't I can't rely on the fact that
I'm the only woman here and you know
that kind of thing so you know I know
that I got a lot of opportunities that I
maybe didn't deserve very early did I
stick the landing on them yes did I
capitalize on them yes but it used to be
they had to put a woman on the lineup so
even though I wasn't funny yet or
talented yet I got a lot of spots that I
didn't deserve right now I have to
actually deserve it because there's a
lot of amazing you know female Comics
out there and they're not putting me on
just because they have to so crazy what
greater equality will do it's a little
bit of a bitch because now I have to
earn it where is some the shit I got for
free that I didn't deserve so I'm only
just speaking in terms of you know the
the the let's say whatever percentage of
people did you know get a little bit of
a leg up because they were a white guy
that now don't get that leg up anymore
I'm sure it does feel like something's
been taken from yeah when in fact they
were just giving something given
something they didn't deserve in the
first place so for me I go well this has
been taken from me and I'm like no just
I was given it unfairly before but it's
hard I think it's hard for people to to
give up things yeah you know and and yet
it's important to move aside and give
other people opportunities and um and
something I will say is you know just to
you know pivot a little bit to
journalism and you as a you know
American icon
you know what I will say is you know I
can't speak for why people are you know
I'm snapping now but I'll speak for
myself which is that you know even
pre-911 I woke up every morning and
Katie was on and it was just I know I
can trust this I started every day with
someone I could trust someone that sort
of soothed my fears someone that had a
great laugh and sense of humor I knew
was going to give me the information you
know at a fair way in an accurate way
was going to tell me everything I needed
to know in order to go through my day we
went through a national trauma with 911
I was at UPenn when it happened uh you
were on the television I ran from my
apartment in Philly to pen you know
um uh and you were on every class had
you on and there was someone there to
sort of soothe the nightmare if that
happened today when the pandemic
happened we didn't have it Katie Couric
to put everything in context and to kind
of soothe us that we could trust and
look to
you don't didn't feel like you could
watch say Anderson Cooper or Savannah
that way and you didn't feel did you
trust what they were saying it's not
that I didn't trust them I just didn't
have an established relationship with
them you know you uniquely and maybe I
just hadn't spent enough time with
Savannah I hadn't sort of you know I
didn't have you know because my parents
watched the muscle memory of of kind of
my Persona being ingrained in your
Morning Experience right and knowing
she's going to ask the question no one
has the audacity to ask she's going to
put everything in context she's going to
use a sense of humor every now and then
when things get dicey you know I just I
had a trust and a love for you that gave
me a sense of security well that's
interesting so so someone works with me
Adriana who wrote her college thesis
about me and it was about sort of the
changing roles of femininity and
broadcast journalism and she talked a
lot about parasocial relationships you
develop with somebody who you watch
regularly or you read regularly or you
see you know could be on a scripted show
but but more I think in in journalism
and I think it's just harder to
establish that relationship because of
the fragmentation of media today it's
you know you can get news it's become so
commoditized you can get it anywhere you
can get it on your phone you can get it
on Twitter get it on Instagram you can
and and so the ability to kind of form
those relationships with the trusted
figure and someone you don't do go to
every day and that it feels almost like
a communal experience because think
about it Whitney when I did the Today
show I started in 1991. so there were
three three news networks really three
morning shows and and CBS was sort of
always kind of lagging behind I don't
think Fox maybe they'd had more local
morning shows it was before Fox News and
and uh you know before Fox News became
Fox News I don't even know when Fox News
the cable channel Fox News Channel
actually started but my point is you had
your local news wherever you lived you
had these big National newspapers like
Chicago The Washington Post the New York
Times Etc the LA times and then you had
ABC NBC and CBS and you had national
public radio and maybe your local radio
station where you got news from them or
you know between songs you were
listening to so it was a much less
you know it there were there there was
not this Paradox of choice and so I
think I was very lucky when I did
when I was in Broadcast News when I did
The Today Show
and we could afford doing things that
that I mean we still had to think about
what was going to get ratings and would
people turn away from certain things but
I think we had this very much this this
drive and this purpose and this desire
to really give people all kinds of
information that they would need I
remember I did a piece on uh Matisse and
Morocco that was at the National Gallery
because I love Matisse and I did like a
long segment on that we do things on
Broadway shows authors you know it was a
real I think I was always so proud at
the end of that show most days at nine
o'clock I'd be like wow we really
contributed to people's ability to
understand the world to be enlightened
about a subject to learn about some kind
of cultural event you know it wasn't
just click bait this person's dead and
it wasn't and it wasn't also just sort
of warm and fuzzy soft like chatting
like we limited I think one mistake
sometimes
because I always it was very cognizant
about the chat portion feeling too
inside baseball because nobody wants to
feel left out right right and sometimes
I think there's too much as my mom would
say uh you know laughing and scratching
yeah on these shows and and and there's
so much information there's so many
important things that people need to
know it's a bit of a waste of time and
also the you want people to be collegial
but they don't have to be you know the
whole Today Show family we always knew
like yeah we're the family the Manson
family we'd make jokes about that right
right you know and so I think that can
be too too heavy-handed and I at times
today I think it is but it just was such
a different world and iPhones didn't
come about till what 2007 2008 so you
know people people went to us it also
used to be in the say I'll just speak
for the Washington Post which I grew up
on right you've got your whether it was
you know already inherently biased just
by what it was covering or not that's a
different conversation but you got your
news and at the in the end it was the
op-ed then you got your opinion right so
it was like it was a very clear
delineation what was fact and what was
an opinion take a Maureen doubt or right
Thomas Friedman who I was writing the
op-ed yeah that at the New York Times or
like a style section piece by Sally
Quinn or yes you're right like now it's
very hard to know if this is all fact or
if there's an agenda behind like that
with the papers well here's what I'll
say I I do get my new I will um watch
Jessica Yellen uh her Instagram and I'll
I really feel a lot of trust with
Jessica
um I feel uh that crystalline Sager uh
breaking points on YouTube I will watch
them but they're both they will sort of
present the facts and then they will
present this is my opinion on this
they'll sort of delineate right I don't
really if I'm gonna be honest like I do
um maybe Vox I'll I'll uh read their
news every now and then and then I do
the AP but I don't Early times for the
post the New York Times yeah
um The New York Times I've sort of sort
of Gotten Good on I mean I just I know
it's a hot take but it's like half their
tweets or recipes I'm just like why are
you posting pie recipes it we're in a it
was a school shooting this morning you
know well they don't do just that they
do you know totally but I think they've
had to try to you know listen it's a dog
eat dog word out there in the world of
media and they need to offer more things
like Wordle and I just heard the the the
um the CEO of the New York Times who's
really a cool woman you would like her
um and Meredith and she was at this
Google Gazette guys thing and they've
been very smart about you know they have
to get people to pay for subscriptions
and the internet was all free for a
while and everybody had to trans
transfer to a paywall because they have
to pay their journalists to do that work
and so I think they just had to be very
creative on how they're going to attract
subscribers and you know I have to say
for myself I love the New York Times I I
think at times they can that that there
is a line between journalism and
activism and I think younger journalists
really see their role as being advocates
for truth justice in the American way
whatever that means to them sure and
that I think also cable news The Prime
Time lineup is just all commentary yeah
um you know oftentimes I don't think
Anderson does as much commentary but and
then I think you know this is such an
interesting subject because I think
during the Trump era which we're not
through with yet it was really hard to
be sort of objective in the traditional
sense of the word yes because you had
someone who was let's be honest lying
you had someone who was uh inciting
riots on January 6th I mean you had
someone who was so morally corrupt it
was really hard to do both sides
journalism and let me ask you about that
because just in general the ethics in
journalism I'm fascinated you know when
Anthony Bourdain you know committed
suicide and then um you know it was Kate
Spade and then you know I had read a
piece I think it was in the Atlantic
years ago about suicide clusters right
about you know when you cover a suicide
and then you know and then everyone says
Rest In Peace So people it's people that
are contemplating suicide go oh that's
where the pieces and then it gives
people the idea and The Bravery to do it
there was this feeder school to Stanford
yes in Palo Alto and I they had a big
and I think it was a train one kid yeah
one kid run in front of a train and then
it was covered and then so I I think I
read that piece too because I was
interested in in that and the I think it
was in the Atlantic
why is everyone covering him so much
like is the best way to well how do you
not cover somebody who's hard for
president of the United States I mean I
think Jeff Zucker has admitted that they
gave him too much uninterrupted air time
right I think Tom Friedman or somebody
wrote a piece
a column in his column in the New York
Times I think he got I think was Nick
Kristoff actually the equivalent of
something like three billion dollars for
free advertising and so I mean listen I
think
it's it's hard this was a phenomenon we
had never really seen
um and I think people sort of were
learning as they were going along and I
think they made a lot of mistakes along
the way but there's ALS always this this
this tension between giving people
important information and because of
corporate ownership of media Outlets
what is going to rate right and you know
how much are they going to be able to
charge advertisers so I think there is
always this conflict there but I think
um I just think Donald Trump's existence
really changed the game and and made it
very difficult to have it be business as
usual in journalism so if you pointed
out things that he had done for people
who liked him you were all you were
biased yeah even though you were
actually just being factual yeah so it
presented a lot of huge challenges and I
you know and and then I think it it
bifurcated media even more with you know
MSNBC and Fox News and then CNN went the
other way but I sort of understand why
CNN went the other way I think what
happened though is it became too much
coverage of the coverage yep you know
this you know Fox News versus CNN and
you know for the average person is that
going to be really helpful
right to tap these these media Wars
going on and and
um I don't know it it it's it's been a
really tough time for journalism and I
think there's so many great journalists
out there who are doing incredible work
and I just think they get painted with
this broad brush and I think that um to
your uh the answer your question about
Anderson Cooper and you know I love
Anderson this is I'm sure getting
trouble for this but you know someone
that you know grew up without money and
is sort of always wondering like what
does someone stand to gain and what are
you know I uh you know I do feel a
little weird that he comes from so much
old money that just me personally just
makes me feel like kind of weird and I
don't know why and that's unfair because
you should be able to be someone that
comes from old money and then says well
I now want to commit to truth and and um
I I'm sure that for some people and
that's interesting that you say that you
know I mean
how in touch can people be with the
average person I mean I was talking to
my husband today and we were talking
about like the economic crisis that is
to come and people are really worried
and suffering and struggling and I said
you know I it's it's sometimes I'm I'm
very relatable but because of what I've
achieved and my station in life it you
know
I don't have proximity to a lot of folks
who are who are dealing with that and
that is a valid criticism of a lot you
know some journalists and that's
something that I have to fight against
you know a big complaint about Hollywood
too it's in order to make it in
Hollywood a lot of times you have to
come for money you have to have you know
well connections connections but you
also have to be able to work for free
for 10 years right you know you have to
have a trust fund right in order to make
it in Hollywood same sort of you know
journalism on one hand I'm saying I
don't really want to you know pay for
news you know because we've all gotten
so bratty number number one you don't
want to pay for news no I mean I do but
when you go like well most people I
think it's like yeah I have to pay for
nine different news networks right right
right the average the truth will be
somewhere in the middle you know I feel
weird getting my news from Just One
Source right right you know so I'm gonna
have to you know pay you know you know
15 a month for 10 different ones I think
the average person is like you know not
get a shell out that you know kind of
money for their news especially the
generation that came from turning on the
TV and getting it for free and younger
Generations see that as normal but older
Generations are like wait you know
um you just throw it at my door you know
uh yeah you have to pay for it back then
yeah but it just felt for some reason
like now that I have to type in a
whatever it is whatever mental block and
I always say we don't have to pay for
porn anymore so it all comes clean in
the wash but on one hand I'm saying I
don't you know I don't know if I want to
get my news from someone who's
independently wealthy but unless we're
paying for news now or allowing the New
York Times to post recipes how is anyone
going to become a journalist if they're
not if they're getting paid a low amount
unless they're independently wealthy so
is the solution we all just have to Buck
Up and really pay for news and even more
so donate to new stop complaining that
you don't like the news you're getting
and that people are biased or come from
independent wealth if you're not going
to either pay extra donate because I'm
the doors that like donates to NPR you
know yeah well I do think you have to
support journalism if you want good
journalism you have to pay for it you
know it just if you want independent
journalism or journalists
um but yeah I I
it's like do you want to do you know
people get their news now just from
random comedians that don't have a
journalism degree and then they complain
I also think there's just so much
information coming at you and I think
one thing that is really critically
important is that you have to learn how
to be a smart
news consumer and it may take an extra
step it may say oh what is this fake AMA
type publication oh it's anti-abortion
that's why they're writing this so you
know it takes a lot of work to really
discern what is you know where there's
an agenda or you know who is actually
doing a story and you know listen I
think people can be objective but
everyone writes and approaches a story
through their own lens and so they're
going to bring their life experiences
some implicit biases which are
unavoidable to whatever they're talking
about they're going to have some kind of
point of view but I I think that they're
still as I said great journalism being
done and and sometimes controversial
journalism being done and just really
quick two things that really helped me
Kathleen Hall Jamison was one of my
professors at Penn and she writing
amazing books about framing of news you
know and then of course Neil postman's
amusing ourselves to death having you
know the infotainment of it all I think
just even educating yourself and and
priming your brain to be able to be a
smart news consumer and also like what
kind of implicit biases am I bringing to
this information or to this story why am
I viscerally reacting this way you know
I try to check myself when it comes to I
mean it's a lot of stuff to think about
but you know I think you
you you have to take some responsibility
yourself you know and and and you have
to be self-critical and you have to I
think
just make sure that you're doing the
work I mean it's of course easier to
read about garbage and I mean listen I
get crime stories on my Apple feed and I
click them I'm like why am I clicking
all these true crime stories and I think
that would be a really interesting
podcast actually like why are people so
obsessed with True Crime
um but but I need to also just have some
discipline and make sure that my news
diet is not all just fluff and garbage
and reality shows I have to say I want
to be informed and this is the thing
these are the things I have to watch and
read in order to be an informed person
and know also that the same way in order
to be healthy you have to watch what you
eat I mean it's you know there's other
places where we've accepted this Dynamic
we know we can't have pizza for dinner
every night you know why do we get
petulant when we're like well I should
be able to just read you you should be
have to tell me that you know you have
to go out of your way to make sure
you're choosing to put the right things
in your brain the same way you have to
choose to put the right things and
I see and we just scroll and we just
kind of absorb whatever's put in front
of us and I think as soon as also you
know I had a wild um Epiphany uh one day
I mean this was like five six years ago
I was sitting next to you know someone
and we were both on this you know
whether it was Huffington Post or
whatever it was and we're both looking
at the same website and I'm like oh this
is crazy and I look over and I realize
we have completely different home pages
because that's based on what I've been
clicking on right they're catering to me
I'm like why is everything a dog rescue
right why is it all personalized which
is I think really bad because it's kind
of giving you what you want and not what
you need may I ask if you could pass any
law today in the news space I.E you know
in advertising there's very strict laws
you have to say not actual size you know
uh things like that uh you have to say
exactly what's in food there's laws
about that right
um do you think that in our lifetime
there will be laws for example I feel
like in our lifetime there will be we
will look back the same way we look back
and go remember when like you could
smoke inside yeah
airplane yeah on an air remember when
like doctors told pregnant women to just
smoke a cigarette if you know I think
we'll look back and go remember when
just anyone like people could just be on
Twitter all day with no breathalyzer
with no qualifications just write
whatever they wanted and it wasn't
vetted by some kind of you know the
problem with vetting it through some
person that decides what's true or not
is who do we decide it's on that piece
right right I think that there will be
laws that will catch up to this
Wilderness you know I think
it's it's hard I vacillate from thinking
the Genies out of the bottle and there's
nothing that can be done and we have to
educate consumers and be smarter about
that and then you see like what happened
to Alex Jones and that gives me hope
then there's this thing called section
230 which
um
which means that these platforms
claim they can't be sued because they're
called platforms they're not Publishers
and so Ergo they bear no responsibility
for the things that travel through their
pipes so there's been a lot of
discussion about you know doing
something about section 230 but there
are a lot of steps that have to happen
first you know like academics don't even
have access to how these social media
platforms work wow and so we have to
work on that we have to do much more
media literacy starting in elementary
school for kids
um we recommended that there are some
people who are quote unquote super
spreaders who have a certain number of
followers where information can be
disseminated quickly and in a widespread
way that they should have to have
certain sort of responsibilities because
they have a huge audience and so I think
I don't know if there's any one thing
that can be done because the problem is
so huge you know President Obama's talks
about disinformation being the biggest
threat to democracy and you can see how
that's the case but it doesn't seem like
it's it still isn't taken really that
seriously and then you see what Elon
Musk is doing over at Twitter and you
think well
is that you know First Amendment rights
or is that just letting hate speech run
amok on these platforms without any kind
of
any kind of editorial or or management
in terms of like looking at the
information taking it down my daughter
Carrie worked for Reuters they were
doing this joint project with Facebook
during the pandemic and her job was to
correct and identify misinformation but
the problem was you know by the time she
would report disinformation by the time
she would report it out by the way they
talk about misinformation disinformation
and Mal information but for our purposes
I'll just say disinformation by the time
she would report out that the vaccine
didn't cause Alzheimer's
you know that thing had spread like
wildfire and so would they say the truth
uh would they say lies run around make
their way around the world before or run
around the world before the truth has a
chance to tie its shoes so it's it's a
it's a big issue and I don't really know
how to solve it and what's interesting
you know they're trying to make CNN more
kind of just the facts ma'am but then
they get pummeled for low ratings right
because do people really want just the
facts have we crossed this Rubicon where
people are into engagement through
enragement they want to feel like tribal
and this visceral feeling like yeah yeah
that's right
um and so it's it's it's a big issue and
I I'm certainly not qualified to solve
it but it's something we we really need
to pay attention to and I think probably
we need a documentary on sort of what
has happened to journalism and that
would be a really interesting you know
thing to dive into one that I um highly
highly recommend not that it solves this
but it just helps helped me understand
how uh looping back to the conspiracy
theory of it all the
um the Q Anon documentary Into the Storm
yeah about how Q Anon you know this
Anonymous person was sort of you know in
the sort of it was fascinating to me to
see how quickly uh these um Mrs La false
Mal information yeah spread and then
sort of the neurochemical drug of uh of
waiting to get some new hot gossip in
the serotonin you get from you know
hearing something crazy and I think you
know something that really helps in that
area is like what makes someone
vulnerable to believing something or
believing someone who has no credibility
and believing something that is so um
you know Sinister and you know not
necessarily true like if we put people
in a situation where they're completely
hopeless of course they're going to be
more vulnerable to this you look at you
know Scandinavian countries and you're
like why isn't that a problem over there
well again I think the point about
income inequality you know about paying
attention to that and about how that
feeds and fuels
um a lot of this I think is is
interesting
um and when we look at like you know
Russia and China and and we think I know
I have to let you go soon we think oh
the thing we find the most disgusting
about those countries I'll speak for
myself is the fact that they control the
information that their citizens have in
order to maintain Empower to keep them
subjugated so it's sort of I think that
you know our long time rivalry with you
know places like Russia and China where
the main thing is oh you don't have
freedom of speech and they completely
control the media to keep their
populations you know ignorant so that
they can maintain this right unfair
power structure It's tricky because
anytime you try to control information
here it goes you know what we can't turn
into China then we're just going to turn
into Russia and it's sort of right right
to negotiate that First Amendment rights
right with then censoring right people
you know that's the tricky one therein
lies the rub and how do we but you know
can we give up a little bit of
quote-unquote free speech in order to
make sure the speech that is
disseminated widely is at least somewhat
accurate yeah but I have hope I I maybe
you know as a comedian again you always
go to the contrarian way and everyone
has no hope right now so well I do I do
I mean I don't know I still think to
your point about journalism there's so
much great journalism being done yeah I
think that we have to really fuck up
those people who are who are doing
the job day in and day out who are you
know in Ukraine risking their lives
covering that story you know they can't
help it if the American public has a
short attention span right that's what
I'll say is like Lord that they they
aren't interested in sort of geopolitics
they'd rather watch Real Housewives I
mean you know like I think I really
admire and respect so many journalism
sorry let me pick that I really admire
and respect so many journalists working
today you know Peter Baker and and Susan
Glasser wrote a great book about Donald
Trump like and it's it's fact-based yeah
and
um you know they're just there's just in
the Atlantic and The New Yorker a lot of
network news correspondents you know
people who are who are covering these
stories that there's there's really
great work being done and so I again I
don't want to paint everyone with a
broad brush it's become an economic
reality for some people to to to be
judged on the click baitness of their
headlines and that's a shame
um and I fall victim to it like anyone
else does but there's there's some
really good work going on in podcasts
and documentaries which I think is the
new long-form journalism and
um so we we need to support those folks
and I think you need to pay for your
subscription you've got to pay for your
news yeah which you pay for it I think
that you know the same way we had a
reckoning in the way that we eat and
people getting sick from what they were
eating there's going to be you're
getting mentally sick from what you're
consuming and then people are you know
it's almost like the new Darwinism in a
way it's just gonna be like you know
you're only as healthy as the news you
consume but there was good news with the
midterms you know democracy lives to see
another day I think people are much
smarter than they're sometimes given
credit for and they saw this real danger
and this pandemic was like a real rock
bottom right so I get excited for yeah
so but I think they saw what some
Republicans wanted to do in terms of
running for Secretary of State and and
subverting the will of the people when
it came to uh election results in a at a
state by state level and and people said
no we can't do that you know our
democracy is precious but it's also
fragile and people have have to have to
remember that I'm letting you go I have
to like John I have to let you go down
Sean is here are your parents here
oh they did oh no The Other Woman come
on we're building a Mormon family yeah
thank God you are still working your
tush off and you are still
um uh around what exactly uh are you
doing right now probably hopefully um I
think we are Instagram followers so we
follow each other so I do we started a
company my husband John and I about four
years ago because I had done sort of
everything in traditional media and I've
been very lucky and I feel very
very fortunate that I had the career I
had and you learned it but and no no no
but you know I I loved it and but I sort
of saw the media landscape changing I
saw disintermediation where you didn't
necessarily need this big infrastructure
you could talk directly to people and
um you know that has pros and cons by
the way when you're not a responsible
person as we've discussed but you know
we just saw this opportunity to be
entrepreneurial in a way I hadn't been
before and really John hadn't been
before so we started this company Katie
Couric media which I would I didn't want
to name it that but John thought listen
you you're a known name a known
commodity so we should take advantage
one of the very few names I think that
well it's harder and nowadays to become
a household name just because they're
everybody's a household name right to a
certain Niche audience but anyway so we
have a newsletter called wake up call we
have you know our our work reaches
millions of people on our website site
our newsletter is called wake up call
people can sign up for it and you know
I'm really proud of the team we've
assembled we have about 40 people now we
have people doing video series we have
digital Series where you know where we
work a lot with mission-driven Brands
because as trust in institutions like
financial institutions or political
institutions and the media have declined
um you know actually people are looking
to companies to stand for something in
addition and not just the bottom line to
care about the environment to care about
gender equality to infuse their their
sort of corporate mentality with
something other than you know quarterly
earnings and and consumers want to buy
things they feel good about and so
companies have gotten into storytelling
and I love storytelling and they're
places where my interests or our
interests and value use that at our
company and their interests intersect
and we can help with storytelling and
that's sort of how it's a it's a
different financial model that's all
branded content it's brand supported
content that we can get behind and
develop and and help them with
storytelling so we're just doing a lot
of different things that's brilliant we
have a shop that is all companies that
that give back or or care about gender
equality or give back to their Community
or environmentally sustainable female
founded uh founded by people of color
um you know lgbtq plus companies so
we're trying to elevate them and use our
our platform to kind of draw attention
to them so people know about these
places that's incredible because I think
a lot of people's biggest you know thorn
in their side at the moment is wait a
second I love what this journalist is
doing but if I really do the math they
work for General Electric or this thing
founded by Saudi money but they have to
do that in order to survive so that's
such a brilliant way to just go ahead
first into that yeah and I think yeah we
are we are truly independent because if
there's anything that I don't want to do
that I deem not worthy or that we deem
not worthy as a company we don't have to
get involved in it but if there's things
that they're you know companies
spotlighting people who are giving back
or women who are breaking glass ceilings
or disrupting certain spaces that we can
that that we can really get behind it's
sort of a win-win for everybody that's
incredible and there are so many Brands
like that like those shoes what are they
top Tom's Shoes yeah you know right
right like that you know they're small
businesses and also big companies big
global companies are now getting into
this space and it you know some people
accuse them of of of green washing you
know not really walking the walk but a
lot of them really are and and so we
want to support what they're doing to
make the planet better to give
opportunities to a broader cross-section
of individuals they're they're doing a
lot of good work can there be a little
section maybe just the info email Katie
section or something where people can
send you
um uh independent journalists that they
like I've started following a couple
people on sub stack that are doing great
stuff that either worked for Heather Cox
Richardson yeah
she's in the entertainment sort of space
was yeah Johnny Depp trial the Weinstein
well you know honestly I've Loved I'd
love to give them more attention you
know because we're looking to to get
more people involved because I don't
want to be the only voice and we you
know are talking to other people who we
can Elevate and they can be part of it
that everyone's sick of me saying
Collective because I've been talking
about it for years in our in our team
but we really want to shine the
spotlight on other up and coming
journalists or journalists who are smart
but maybe want to expand Their audience
and I think hopefully if I give them you
know if they have our impromature or
impromatter I don't know how people say
that but you know it it can it can be
helpful to them too and introduce them
to a bigger audience of people and it
can be interesting for you to be able to
say like who do people like yeah and I
would love to know and why and who are
people responding to and why and then
vet to make sure that all of it's
actually true right go oh great well you
know we do have like you know I do a lot
of work with Mark Hyman for example who
does a lot of of wellness and is a
functional medicine doctor used to be at
the Cleveland Clinic and you know we
have other people that we turn to for
sort of political views and you know so
we we are trying to kind of expand the
number of voices we feature on our
platform and then in terms of the last
thing I'll say the when I think forward
I would love within the next five ten
years the same way that you know a tweet
is verified because they are verifying I
want to see a news tweet that's verified
by you or by your website right you know
right because like this has been vetted
this person is you know yeah because
that's you know I suggested that and I
think it's complicated I wanted to I
thought that we could do kind of a Good
Housekeeping seal of approval for and I
know that there are organizations like
Steve Brill started one I forget what
it's called
um we can look it up but but
I think the problem there is better
vetted by whom sure right and I I think
I would feel comfortable or vetted by
the Annenberg School sure right you know
some some organization or academic
institution like that I think that would
be really helpful to people 100 but um I
don't think that idea has gotten a lot
of traction for whatever reason I think
that I think uh it's probably very
threatening to a lot of people that
there would sort of be uh uh rules in
any way shape or form and but and I
guess that also maybe it hurts like up
and coming uh organizations I don't know
but I do think if consumers knew that
there were certain rules and certain
things
right protocols that yeah that that
reporters had to go through in terms of
editors and fact checking and you know
two sources or if they use an anonymous
source they have to explain why you know
and and the New York Times The
Washington Post and AP and all these
important Publications do follow those
rules but you know it's also very
interesting when I was on this I was the
chair co-chair of a disinformation
commission at the Aspen Institute and I
remember talking about the good old days
you know when there weren't that many
outlets and there was Walter Cronkite
and uh Rashad Robinson who who's the
head of an organization called color of
change said you know I wouldn't be too
nostalgic about those days because they
were very
um
they were very exclusive and not
inclusive of all different voices of uh
you know there weren't many female
voices there weren't many black voices
there weren't voices representing people
from from all walks of life and I think
that's a really important point for all
the shit that gets out there online that
suddenly a lot of people who heretofore
didn't have a voice or didn't have
Outlets or now it's it has leveled the
playing field in a lot of ways I'm gonna
throw one thing at you because I do
think that
um uh you know networks like the Grio
and you know right you know which Byron
Allen now
Byron Allen about that right I know and
so maybe it's or the root you know yeah
exactly because I mean sometimes you
know someone of color is like I kind of
want to go to the place that's all
people have where I could be you know
instead of like I have to be the one
person in an all you know uh White new
who care whatever they choose but I
think although I don't think that exists
at any more quite so much oh exactly
whatever it is whatever version you know
but also you know collaborating with you
know the other news networks that you
know exclusively reach a certain you
know group
um and you know instead of assuming
everyone's gonna reach everyone and we
have to you know well I think I often
say and that mass media has become an
oxymoron and that the days of everybody
watching or reading the same thing just
isn't going to happen anymore sure so
how do you try to ensure that at least
the niche media you know has has certain
standards totally totally or that just
supporting a niche media for someone
that wants to make sure that they're you
know getting every angle of something so
yeah maybe having you know a little a
little Byron Allen yeah that's
interesting I've been reading a little
bit about that that's interesting yeah
anyway you're the greatest I love you
you so much thank you so much
what a dream you don't need the Good
Housekeeping seal approval because if
you really want information you can
trust the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal exists so whatever your
political I think yeah
New York Times people do not but fine so
then if you don't but then
there's still red elephants
[Music]
[Applause]